madison kimbrough is joining us live now
from allegion stadium as well where
we've seen parking issues in the past in
madison with tonight's influx of people
we saw earlier did traffic and parking
continue to bring problems for fans
yeah we got mixed reaction tonight but
for the most part everyone was in
positive spirits just happy to finally
be able to attend a raiders game here at
the stadium
we did park like a mile away which was
50
saturday marked the las vegas raiders
preseason kickoff at allegiant stadium
where for the first time raider nation
was allowed inside the stadium but with
the addition of fans many worried about
the dreaded parking issues allegiant
stadium has seen in the past we heard
from several fans who were both
satisfied with today's parking options
but also some that were a bit frustrated
too i got a
season pass for parking i had to pay for
it but i'm in lodex right over there so
it's really i just have this walk so
it's really good for me i was actually a
lot worse than i thought it was going to
be and i'm on a motorcycle so that's
even like you know i thought i was going
to be able to find a spot anywhere but
it was actually really difficult to be
honest from 60 to 80 dollars there were
several lots taking advantage of those
fans that didn't buy parking passes with
their tickets most just happy to be
going to a game in person like las vegas
fan marvin preston parking's a little
bit further out but i mean it wasn't bad
you know and 50 bucks and maybe like a
mile and a half away
but that's not stopping you we're raider
fans ain't gonna stop us other than
marvin most fans shared that parking was
available but it just costed more than
they would have liked
again the next home game is going to be
against the baltimore ravens that's
going to be monday september 13th
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now